abriéndose camino en medio de un océano
de basura
vemos plástico allí en la naturaleza no
sabemos lo que va a generar después
consternado de 10 del pib describe las
toneladas de residuos que descansan bajo
sus pies ambientó tuberías pintura que
se han votado allí ilegalmente tan solo
20 km de parís junto al bosque de bernuy
un espacio natural protegido este
vertedero no autorizado ocupa más de 16
hectáreas un desastre según tufik
es muy doloroso saber que podría ser un
entorno para los niños para todo el
mundo para poder pasearse hay mucho
bosque de árboles está muy bien y en
este momento francamente es repugnante
los contaminadores son profesionales que
quieren evitar pagar el servicio de
vertedero aunque incluso les cobran a
sus clientes algunos particulares
aceptan recibir los desechos ilegalmente
por un precio de dos a cuatro euros por
tonelada un negocio muy jugoso
es menos peligroso es menos riesgoso que
la criminalidad a gran escala produce
mucho dinero varios millones de euros
eso es seguro incluso varias decenas de
millones de euros esta catástrofe
medioambiental es también una de las
causas del calentamiento global debido a
que la fermentación de esos residuos
produce metano un gas con efecto
invernadero 25 veces más que el co2
estimamos que cerca del 20 por ciento de
las emisiones de metano en francia-
proviene de los vertederos en los que
terminan gran parte de nuestros desechos
y la otra parte de éstos acaban en un
incinerador que expulsa humos al aire lo
que contribuye a la polución
la polución también está bajo tierra
este agricultor compro compostaje pero
fue estafado su terreno se transformó
ilegalmente en un lugar de depósito de
tierras contaminadas
no puedo sembrar como no puedo sembrar
no puedo cultivar plantas si no puedo
cultivar plantas no puedo alimentar a mi
granja no puedo generar ningún volumen
de negocio sigue siendo lo que me da de
vivir cuando vengo a ver el campo me
duele el corazón porque es mi
herramienta de trabajo yo no pedí esto
no lo compré fragma sepa como dónde saca
el gestesa los contaminadores pueden
enfrentarse a multas que van hasta 75
mil euros y dos años de prisión por
abandonar o dejar desechos fuera de los
lugares autorizados